[Applaudissements]
merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
je voudrais m'associer toute à la fois à
vos mots et à ceux de madame la
Présidente oui c'est avec sidération et
horreur que nous avons reçu samedi matin
ces images
terrifiantes horribles venant
d'Israël des massacres de civils étaient
perpétrés des vieillards ont été traqué
jusque dans leur
domicile des enfants ont été kidnappés
des femmes ont été violées
aujourd'hui les terroristes du Hamas qui
ont commis ces exactions
terrifiantes menacent d'assassiner les
otages dans d'autres temps dans d'autres
lieux nous avons connu les mêmes
scénarios à l'image de ce 13 novembre
2015 sur les terrasses parisiennes où
des jeunes
comme dans le désert du Négev ont été
pris pour cible à l'image du 14 juillet
2016 à Nice alors notre réaction elle
doit être celle de tous les républicains
de tous ceux qui sont attachés à la
liberté c'est-à-dire condamner sans
réserve ceux qui ont commis ces
exactions ces terroristes elle doit être
aussi de soutenir
totalement Israël en lui exprimant notre
fraternité en humanité
au-delà de ce soutien au-delà cette
émotion madame la Première ministre des
réactions doivent intervenir nous ne
pouvons plus aujourd'hui je le dis et
c'est le sens de la résolution des
républicains accorder du financement
public à ceux qui soutiennent ou
financent le terrorisme
imaginons pouvons-nous
imaginer pouvons-nous
imaginer la France financer
daesh et bien aujourd'hui nous le disons
il faut couper toute aide au
développement à ceux qui participent au
financement du terrorisme et il faut
sanctionner il faut
sanctionner et il
fctionner lourdement totalement les
États comme l'Iran et le Qatar qui
financent le terrorisme madame la
Première ministre et êtes-vous prête je
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remercie je vous
remercie madame la Présidente panneau
pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre nos pensées se
tournent à vers le Proche Orient où les
peuples Israéliens et Palestiniens
souffrent encore une fois je souhaite
depuis cette assemblée exprimer une
pensée emplie d'humanité pour les otages
les civils tués en Israël par les actes
de terreur perpétrés par le Hamas ainsi
que pour les civils qui à Gaza sont tués
sous les bombes de tsal nous condamnons
tous ces crimes de
guerre un seul message doit parvenir du
concert des nations en cette heure si
grave qui n'est en rien propice aux
polémiques franco-français un seul
message doit parvenir du concert des
nations cessz le feu c'est un message
qui nous vient du Secrétaire général des
Nations unies du pape ou de Loula qui
préside le Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies cessz le feu car le pire
est à prévoir quand le ministre de la
Défense israélien assiège Gaza privant 2
millions de civiles d'eau d'électricité
et de nourriture violation du droit
international face auquel la France ne
peut rester
silencieuse nous n'avons jamais eu
autant besoin du courage de la paix que
dans ces moments cela fait trop
longtemps que la communauté
internationale a laissé la situation
sans venimer de communiqués du K d'orsé
un communiqué du président de la
République pas un appel au cesser le feu
pas une fois le mot paix notre pays rond
avec la tradition diplomatique qui est
la notre au Proche Orient depuis 65 ans
il nous faut uvrer au rétablissement
d'un processus de paix qui mène à deux
états sans quoi les horreurs passées
s'amplifieront non seulement des
atrocités présentes mais aussi des
désastres à venir aucune paix durable ne
peut voir le jour sans respect du droit
international et sans mettre fin à la
colonisation alors allez-vous madame la
Première ministre retrouver la voix
indépendante qu'a toujours porté la
France de Charles de Gaul
àirac la voix de la France qui quand
elle parle est écouté la voix de la
France qui fait entendre la parole de la
paix et ne s'aligne pas sur les
positions VAT en guerre d'un
gouvernement d'extrême droite la voix de
la France qui Fa réaffirme que toutes
les vies comptent sans exception la
France madame la Première ministre
va-t-elle retrouver la langue de la
paix la parole est à Monsieur le
présidentard pour le groupe
[Musique]
naissance
merci
merci monsieur le Président
allez-y merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre il
s'appelait Tamar et Yonathan ils étaient
parents de trois enfants et ont été tués
dans leur foyer il s'appellent
Ariel ditsa noir ce sont des mères de
famille des enfants des personnes âgées
des adolescents enlevé et pris en otage
actuellement dans la bande de Gaza tous
sont des victimes du terrorisme du Hamas
qui depuis samedi sème la mort et la
désolation en Israël déjà 900 civiles
tués dont quatre de nos compatriotes et
plus de 2600 blessés des victimes
assassinées mtilées parce
qu'israélienne près de 150 otages qui
vivent en ce moment même l'insoutenable
attendent que leurs joliers les
marchandent certains de nos
ressortissants pourraient même être
parmi eux alors que nous sommes toujours
sans nouvelle de 13 d'entre eux j'ai une
pensée particulière pour etan un enfant
un français de 12 ans ce climat de
terreur certains voudraient même le
créer sur notre sol alors qu'une
vingtaine d'attaques antisémites ont été
relevées en 2 jours il est du devoir de
la représentation nationale de dénoncer
avec force ces actes de haine qui sapent
nos principe car toucher à un citoyen
juif c'est toucher à la République dans
ce combat commun de nos démocraties
contre la terreur la complaisance
aveugle l'ambiguité coupable sont
intolérables car rien absolument rien et
je dis vraiment absolument rien ne
justifie le
terrorisme
le président de la République l'a
réaffirmé avec plusieurs de nos alliés
Israël a le droit de se défendre madame
la Première ministre comment le
gouvernement compte-il assurer la
sécurité de nos concitoyens sur place
mais également sur notre propre
territoire je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
national madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues ce 7
octobre 2023 nous avons assisté à ce que
nous pensions ne plus jamais revoir dans
l'histoire de l'humanité des porommes
des porommes sur la terre même d'Israël
au cours desqueles on a tué des femmes
des enfants des hommes uniquement parce
qu'ils étaient juifs ces attaques sont
un crime contre les humains mais aussi
un crime contre la paix contre cet
extraordinaire élan processus qui ces
derniers mois semblait progresser
rapprochant Israël et les nations
arabes nous Français nous avons revécu
avec froid les horreurs du Bataclan ou
les tueres d'enfants de Mohamed Mera les
scènes d'une violence inouie contre des
civils ou des militaire blessés ou tués
les prises d'otage y compris de
personnes âgées et d'enfants sont d'un
inhumanité
rare je veux dire ici que ceux qui
soutiennent l'insoutenable l'excuse ou
le relativise et dont certains siègent
sur ses bancs attenteent aux valeurs
humaines
il ils en répondront politiquement y
compris vis-à-vis de leurs alliés et le
cas échéant devant la justice je
réaffirme ici solenellement notre
soutien au peuple israélien frappé au
cœur aux familles touchées dans leur
chair et à tous ceux qui souffrent dans
leur âme de ces abomination la lutte
contre l'IDRE islamiste que ce soit en
Israël ou en France est un enger majeur
pour notre
notamment car elle doit libérer
certaines populations dont je crois une
partie du peuple palestinien prise en
otage par des mouvements islamiste
terroriste cette lutte demande des
moyens mais elle demande surtout une
volonté politique pour nous responsables
politiques français l'urgence est
aujourd'hui de protéger physiquement
mais aussi moralement les Français juifs
si sur le plan physique le gouvernement
a annoncé le déploiement de forces de
l'ordre sur le plan moral comment
comptez-vous faire respecter en France
l'interdiction de la apologie du
terrorisme première étape dans la lutte
contre
l'islamisme je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier for pour le groupe
socialiste madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
le massacre de jeunes a une r partie
l'exécution de bébés de vieillard
innocent le kidnapping d'otage y compris
d'enfant n'est pas un acte de résistance
c'est un crime
terroriste les actes du Hamas doivent
être condamnés comme leur projet
politique qui n'est pas la paix et qui
exclut toute coexistence avec l'État
d'Israël notre condamnation est totale
le terrorisme n'est pas un moyen
d'expression aucune cause ne le justifie
aucun contexte ne
l'excuse la fin ne justifie jamais les
moyens j'exprime ici au nom des
socialistes notre solidarité avec les
familles des victimes et le peuple
israélien
traumatisé chacun le sait désormais
l'embrasement est possible il y a un
scénario du pire qui s'écrit sous nos
yeux la tentation du chaos existe elle
est portée par tous ceux qui du àasse à
l'extrême droite israélienne ont tout
fait pour tuer les accords d'Oslo la
riposte ne donc ne peut donc pas être la
vengeance aveugle notre soutien à Israël
comme à toute démocratie frappée par le
terrorisme est indéfectible dans les
limites du droit
international le droit humanitaire doit
être respecté le siège de Gaza n'est pas
acceptable la déshumanisation des
Palestiniens par le ministre israélien
de la Défense est une insulte à notre
commune humanité infliger une punition
collective à des populations civiles est
insupportable chaque vie
compte notre conviction est inchangé il
n'y aura pas de paix durable sans État
palestinien et sans garantie de sécurité
pour Israël nous appelons dans
l'immédiat le gouvernement français et
l'Union européenne à prendre une
initiative diplomatique pour inesser le
feu avant de convoquer ultérieurement un
sommet pour une issue politique la
guerre à ces trop nombreux partisans la
paix a maintenant besoin de ses
combattants merci je vous
remercie
la parole est à monsieur le Président
marcangelli pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre le 7 octobre
2023 restera dans l'histoire comme un
jour où le genre humain a montré sa face
la plus sombre le Hamas a mis en œuvre
une attaque organisée coordonné visant à
prendre le maximum de civil israéliens
en otage quand il n'était pas somma
exécuté chez eux parfois par famille
entière ce ne sont pas des crimes de
guerre une qualification qui s'applique
uniquement lorsqu'ils sont commis par
une armée régulière ici les méthodes
employées ont changé de nature et de
degré
elles sont en effet désormais
comparables à ce que l'État islamique a
pu faire de pire
le groupe horizon et apparenté condamne
fermement et unanimement ces actes
terroristes perpétré par une
organisation terroriste il n'y a pas de
place pour aucune ambigué qui
bénéficierait à ceux qui commettent des
opérations barbares sur des femmes et
des enfants nous sommes solidaires du
peuple israélien et de toutes les
victimes je veux avoir une pensée
particulière pour les familles des
quatre Français dont la mort a été
confirmée à cette heure par le qu d'orsé
et celle qui sont encore dans une longue
et douloureuse attente la vérité c'est
que la cause palestinienne mérite mieux
qu'une organisation islamiste terroriste
qui n'hésite pas à prendre des
populations civiles qu'elles soient
israéliennees ou palestiniennes comme
boucliers
humains et plus personne n'ignore que le
but ultime du Hamas n'est pas la paix
mais bien la destruction pure et simple
de l'État d'Israël
madame la Première ministre pouvez-vous
indiquer à la représentation nationale
quelle mesure la France compte prendre
pour assurer le rapatriement de nos
ressortissants lorsqu'ils le demande
comment prévenir ensuite l'importation
de ce conflit dans notre pays plus
généralement enfin quelle est la
position de la France sur l'évolution de
la situation au Moyen-Orient et en
Méditerranée je vous remercie merci
beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Présidente
châelin pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre chers collègues les
écologistes pensent aux familles aux
victimes à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont dans l'angoisse et dans l'attente
de nouvelles de leurs proches notre
solidarité est totale les Israéliens ont
le droit absolu de pouvoir vivre en
sécurité les écologistes condamnent sans
réserve les atrocités commises par les
terroristes du Hamas aucune lutte ne
justifie les tirs de roquettes contre un
hôpital aucune cause ne justifie la
prise d'otage et l'assassinat de civil
aucun acte de résistance ne justifie le
massacre de 260
festivaliers les écologistes ne seront
jamais au côté de de celles et ceux qui
sèment la terreur et la mort nous serons
toujours au côté de celles et ceux qui
uvre pour la
paix face à la barbarie seul le droit
international est
réponse
aujourd'hui les bombardements incessants
de Gaza et la mise en place d'un siège
total privant 2,3 millions de Gazaoui
d'eau de nourriture et d'électricité
nous alarme au plus haut point les
propos déshumanisant du ministre
israélien de la Défense comparant les
Gazaoui à des animaux laisse crainre un
massacre dans la prison à C l'ouvert que
Gaza nous ne pouvons plus tolérer cela
la communauté internationale a fait le
Paris que le conflit israël-palestinien
s tiendrait de lui-même il a fait le
choix de regarder ailleurs les 72
dernières heures nous rappellent à quel
point c'est une question géopolitique
centrale et la France a une
responsabilité majeure en tant que
membre permanent du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies le gouvernement
français ne peut se contenter d'apporter
un soutien aveugle au gouvernement
israélien la France doit réaffirmer sa
position historique pour la coexistence
de deux états vivant en paix et en
sécurité les Palestiniens ont le dro
absolu de vivre libre dans un état
souverain l'urgence est donc cesser le
feu au respect du droit international et
à la protection des civils madame la
Première ministre comment votre
gouvernement compte-il agir en faveur de
la déescalade comment la France
compte-elle au sein d'une démarche
européenne agir résolument pour la paix
et la protection des civils je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur le
Président matthi pour le groupe
démocrate madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre quelle que soit la
cause que l'on défend elle restera
toujours déshonoré par le massacre
aveugle d'une foule innocente où le
tueur c'est d'avance qu'il atteindra la
femme et l'enfant disait Albert Camu
depuis samedi dernier les populations
civiles israéliennes sont victimes d'une
attaque terroriste massive et sans
précédent de la part du Hamas qui a
causé l'effroid dans la population
israélienne plus de 700 personnes ont
été assassinées dont plus de
250 personnes qui participaient à un
moment de fête plus de 150 israéliens
hommes femmes et enfants sont retenus en
otage par les terroristes du Hamas dans
la bande de Gaza des quartiers et des
villages ont été réduit en cendre et les
roquettes continuent de pleuvoir sur les
ville israélienne mettant en danger plus
de 9 millions de civils cette violence
nous indigne et nous verse profondément
et ne peut laisser la place à aucune
ambiguitité d'interprétation quant aux
motivations de ce groupe terroriste face
à ces crimes nous ne pouvons rester
silencieux ou pire indulgent je veux le
dire simplement aucune lutte ne justifie
le terrorisme aucun conflit territorial
n'explique ces horreurs car au-delà des
communautés c'est bien la dignité et
l'humanité qui sont aujourd'hui
attaqués
nous condamnons fermement ces attentats
les manifestations nombreuses qui ont eu
lieu hier en fin de journée ont marqué
la solidarité du peuple de France
vis-à-vis du peuple israélien si
durement touché nous étions nombreux à y
être et j'avoue avoir été
particulièrement touché par la
fraternité qui s'est exprimé je veux
dire au nom du groupe de mon groupe tout
notre soutien au peuple israélien nous
adressons nos condolances aux proches
des victimes de ces attentats et sommes
au côté des des familles des otages
madame la Première ministre pouvezous
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles seront les
actions à venir de la France et de
l'Europe surtout dans ce contexte de
crise aigu je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pancher pour le groupe lot
madame la Première ministre les députés
du groupe lot comme le monde entier ont
découvert eux aussi avec effroi les
attaques du mouvement terroriste Hamas
contre la population civile israélienne
c'est avec la plus grande fermeté que
nous les condamnons sans aucune réserve
queles que soient les causes les humains
ne peuvent pas en arriver à de tels
niveau d'atrocité sur leur semblables
les assassinats les prises d' Tage
d'enfants d'adultes de femmes ou de
personnes âgées sont des actes
monstrueux nous apportons notre totale
solidarité aux familles aux proches des
victimes des disparus des otages du
Hamas prises dans un chantage odieux il
s'agit pour la représentation française
et pour les responsables politiques que
nous sommes de faire preuve de
responsabilité et de dignité dans notre
expression loin de toute querelle
politicienne les prises de position avec
de la surenchè sans aucune nuance celles
cherchant des excuses ou appelant à la
vengeance ne peuvent décemment être
acceptable ou prise avec un conflit
d'une telle complexité nul ici ne peut
régler ses compte avec d'autres car ce
serait une offense aux victimes et à
ceux qui continuent de souffrir ceux qui
sont dans l'angoisse d'un enfant ou d'un
parent disparu et qui craignent pour
leur vie je le dis avec solennité il est
essentiel que nous donnions tous une
autre image que celle que nous voyons
parfois dans cette hémicycle nous avons
appris ce matin malheureusement la mort
de quatre Français nous apportons
évidemment notre soutien et nos
condoléances à leurs famill à leurs
proches nous demandons au gouvernement
les solutions qu'il va mettre en place
pour nos ressortissants actuellement en
Israël et qui souhaite revenir en France
nous craignons un déluge de feu à venir
et un élargissement du conflit il
appartient au-delà de l'émotion légitime
immédiate que la France l'Union
européenne et l'ONU puissent commencer à
envisager des solutions pour éviter un
engrenage incontrôlable madame la
Première ministre c'est dans ce sens
qu'il nous faut tous
vrer je vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
remerci la parole est àieés
madame la Première ministre le groupe
GDR et les députés communistes ont
condamné sans réserve l'attaque
terroriste perpétrée par le Hamas sur
les civils
israéliens nous avons nous avons nous
avons exprimé comme tous ici notre plus
profonde émotion face à la violence
aveugle qui s'est déchaîné sur des
femmes des enfants des vieillards une
condamnation qui s'impose mais elle ne
suffira pas à mettre fin aux violences à
protéger les populations à trouver le
chemin de la paix et de la sécurité
aujourd'hui Gaza est sous le feu des
bombes privé d'eau et
d'électricité le gouvernement israélien
israélien d'extrême droite promet de
traiter ses habit comme des animaux une
vengeance terrifiante qui s'abat là
aussi sur des femmes des enfants des
vieillards des millions de civils
innocents la France doit aussi madame la
Première ministre condamner cette
opération vengeresse qui va plonger plus
encore les peuples les Israéliens et
Palestiniens dans le désespoir et le
deuil la France doit lancer une
initiative diplomatique forte pour
imposer le respect du droit et mettre
fin à 75 ans de duplicité de la
communauté internationale sur la
question
palestinienne une communauté
internationale qui par la voix de l'ONU
condamne la politique colonialiste
israélienne et le traitement réservé aux
Palestiniens privés de leurs droits
fondamentaux une communauté
internationale qui ferme les yeux sur
les résolutions Bafou par Israël la
France doit reprendre le flambeau de la
paix qu'elle a abandonné depuis tant
d'années être à l'initiative d'un
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qui mette
fin à la politique d'occupation et se
consacre à la recherche d'une solution à
deux états
coexistants un état pour le peuple
israélien et un état pour le peuple
palestinien deux États dont les
frontières seraient protégé communauté
internationale alors alors seulement
seulement nous gagnerons une paix
durable pour mettre fin à la spirale
destructrice je vous
remercie chaque groupe politique s'étant
exprimé je donne la parole à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les présidentes Messieurs les
Présidents les présidents mesdames et
messieurs les
députés ce samedi 7 octobre l'horreur
s'est abattu sur plusieurs villes
d'Israël et quelques heures plus tard
nous allions découvrir l'ampleur la
gravité et la barbarie de l'attaque
terroriste commise par le Hamas des tirs
de roquettes massifs des civils visés
des femmes des hommes homes des
personnes âgées des enfants exhibés
humiliés pris en otage tués ces images
ont été un choc elles étaient
probablement encore en dessous de la
réalité dans les heures qui ont suivi
nous avons découvert 260 victimes dans
le désert des jeunes femmes et des
jeunes hommes sauvagement tué et encore
ce matin nous sommes frappés par
l'horreur avec la découverte d'un
charnier d'une centaine de corps dans le
kibuts de Berry à l'est de
Gaza ces drames ont un retentissement
particulier en
France notre pays connaît trop bien le
prix et les souffrances du
terrorisme notre pays a un rôle à tenir
pour défendre toujours la démocratie et
la
liberté à nouveau je veux dire mon
soutien aux victimes et aux familles
dont nous partageons la
douleur permettez-moi comme vous l'avez
fait messieurs mesdames et Messieurs les
présidentes et présidents d'avoir une
pensée particulière pour les familles
françaises qui souffre
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous déplorons à l'heure
actuelle quatre décès parmi nos
ressortissants et nous cherchons encore
des nouvelles de 13 de nos compatriotes
dont la situation est extrêmement
préoccupante certains sont probablement
pris en otage parmi eux un enfant de 12
ans nous sommes en lien constant avec
les familles et mes pensées vont vers
elles et nous veillons en lien avec Air
France à ce que des vols puissent
reprendre au plus
vite nous sommes face à une attaque
terroriste commise par un groupe
terroriste le Hamas un groupe reconnu
comme tel par la France comme par
l'Union
[Applaudissements]
européenne une attaque commise avec
l'aide du Djihad islamique qui a aussi
revendiqué ses actes une attaque odieuse
inaccepttable encore tout à l'heure le
président de la République s'est exprimé
dans les termes les plus clairs
nous condamnons ces actes avec la plus
grande fermeté l'ensemble des
démocraties du monde les ont condamné
avec la plus grande fermeté c'est la
seule réponse possible sans
ambiguïé mesdames et messieurs les
députés ne nous trompons pas sur ce qui
vient de se passer nous faisons face à
un changement d'échc
l'ampleur de l'opération sa complexité
son exécution tous ces éléments le
démontrent la barbarie et le niveau de
violence inimaginable nous rappelleent
les pires moments de notre combat contre
l'État
islamique ceux qui ont soutenu financé
et armé le Hamas ont basculé avec lui
dans
l'ignominie
dans ces heures graves la responsabilité
doit guider notre
action notre message est clair le
président de la République l'a rappelé
ce matin d'abord un soutien total à
Israël et à sa population nous nous
tenons à leur côté et Israël a le droit
de se défendre face au
[Applaudissements]
terrorisme
face à la barbarie des attaques
terroristes personne ne peut lui déger
ce droit
ensuite nous devons tout mettre en œuvre
pour permettre la désescalade et éviter
l'embrasement de la région tous les
civils doivent être protégés et le droit
international
respectter
la diplomatie est à l'œuvre le président
de la République a multiplié les
échanges avec ses homologues la ministre
des Affaires étrangères est pleinement
mobilisée avec l'ensemble de nos
Diplomat nous restons en contact très
étroit avec nos partenaires dans la
région chacun doit mesurer les risques
de la
situation enfin je veux le dire nous
sommes vigilants dans notre pays et nous
ne tolérons aucun acte aucun propos
antisémite en
France nous ne laisserons passer aucun
débordement ni sur la voie publique ni
dans l'espace numérique notre cadre
républicain est clair il s'appliquera
avec la plus grande fermeté à tous ceux
qui voudrait utiliser ce conflit comme
prétexte à l'antisémitisme que ce soit
dans nos rues dans nos écoles dans nos
[Applaudissements]
universités et je veux adresser un
message à la communauté juive de notre
pays choqué et dont je mesure l'angoisse
nous sommes avec vous s'en prendre à
vous c'est s'en prendre à toute la
République
dès samedi le ministre de l'Intérieur a
adressé des messages de vigilance à tous
les préfets et aux forces de l'ordre
avec le concours des militaires de
sentinelle la protection des lieux
sensibles a été renforcée enfin nos
services de renseignement travaille
activement à la détection des menaces
afin de prévenir tout acte de violence
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
veux également être clair sur un point
la France a toujours été l'artisan de la
paix elle le reste et malgré l'horreur
des événements ces violences
injustifiables ne doivent pas nous nous
détourner de la recherche d'une paix
durable au Moyen-Orient et d'une
solution politique dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien le le Hamas ne
cherche pas à répondre à ses aspirations
il a démontré que son seul obj
c'est de faire couler le sang dans ce
contexte je n'ignore pas les
interrogations sur notre aide
humanitaire notre aide est versée à des
organismes de l'ONU sur place qui
agissent directement pour l'accès à
l'eau la sécurité alimentaire la santé
ou l'éducation nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants à ce qu'aucun euro d'ê
française ne parviennent à une
quelconque organisation terroriste ni à
Gaza ni
ailleurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés Israël un pays ami et allié vit
un traumatisme terrible un un
traumatisme qui nous replonge 50 ans en
arrière notre devoir est d'être au côté
de la
démocratie notre devoir est de dénoncer
sans relâche le terrorisme notre notre
devoir et de tout mettre en œuvre pour
trouver le chemin de la paix grâce à la
diplomatie ce chemin sera très long mais
nous ne pouvons pas baisser les bras
nous devons tout faire pour trouver une
solution politique et mettre fin aux
décennies de ce conflit territorial la
France tiendra sa place dans ces moments
tragiques je trouve choquant et désolant
d'entendre des voix dissonnantes jusque
jusque sur ces bancs c'est par la
cohésion nationale et par la défense de
nos valeurs républicaines que nous
pourrons être à la hauteur je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre je vous
remercie